what is up everybody its Anna Mack here
for anime uproar and today I will be
breaking down the latest developments in
the attack on Titan story and I will
explore the question of who is the real
traitor here is it Reiner and Annie is
it Eren himself is it Armin and Mikasa
is it the Jaeger ist's or is it someone
else entirely whom should we condemned
as a traitor who betrayed their own
comrades and their own ideals and whom
should we praise as honorable and heroic
this is not an easy question to answer
in attack on Titan but that is what I
will be doing in this video before we
dive into it a quick thank you to
summoners war for sponsoring this video
summoners war is the classic mobile
turn-based RPG a game with 110 million
installs and a massive global community
of fans I really enjoy this game
I love the awesome battle animation and
I also love that strategy plays an
important role just for fun I tried
clicking random skills and attacks to
see what would happen and I quickly
realized that in order to win I need to
actually strategize picking the right
skill and move at the right time matters
a lot and that's what makes this game so
much fun summoners war is currently
celebrating their sixth anniversary by
giving away 100 free summons so you have
to check it out there are over 1,000
unique monsters to collect a global PvP
arena featuring real-time battles
against other players from all over the
world weekly in-game events and so much
more check it out for yourself just
click the link in the description to
download summoners war for free jump
into the action customize your very own
sky island summon your monsters and join
the huge global community of players
just click the link in the description
to download summoners war for free on
Android and iOS look at this epic
lightning summon gargoyle who will use
summon just a heads up this video will
contain attack on Titan manga spoilers I
will be referring to all the latest
available manga information so if you're
not caught up to the manga please
proceed with caution you
have been warned interestingly enough
chapter one to eight of the attack on
Titan manga is called traitor and this
really made me think about who the true
traitor is in this whole story at this
point in attack on Titan numerous
prominent Scouts including Levi Mikasa
Armin Han Jie Connie and John have
decided to ally themselves with their
former enemies I am of course talking
about the Marlin warriors including
Annie Reiner Peake and McGrath it goes
without saying that during the early
part of attack on Titan
Annie Reiner and bertolt were the
obvious traitors they infiltrated the
island joined the Training Corps
befriended their fellow recruits and
then eventually betrayed them all the
actions of these three led to the deaths
of countless people on the island
including one of their own close friends
Marko as a result of their betrayal
Marko became half the man he used to be
there are you happy comments section I'm
always seeing this joke whenever I
mention Marko in a video so this time I
beat you to it as we know the unlikely
alliance between the Marlins and the
scouts was formed because of their
common commitment to stop Eren from
destroying the entire world even though
they still have many points of
disagreement the Allies all agree that
Aaron's plan to kill everyone in the
world except for the people on Paradise
Island is a step too far and they feel
compelled to stop this from happening
the Marlins want to save their own
families and the innocent people of
Marley which makes sense from their
perspective but it turns out that even
Aaron's close friends like Mikasa and
Armin believed that the innocent people
of the world should be spared and what's
more they're willing to risk their own
lives to stop Aaron's destruction these
unlikely allies now find themselves
facing off against the Jaeger ists the
zealous supporters of Aaron and his plan
who are currently being led by the true
divine emperor of the universe His
Excellency floc Forrester Stormborn the
first of his name the breaker of chains
the
mother of dragons fun fact but that is
flocks full legal name and title look it
up according to the Jaeger ists the
world has been trying to destroy the LD
ends on parodies for centuries the rest
of the world demonizes the Islanders as
evil Devils who must be destroyed for
the good of humanity and so every time
the Islanders tried to seek peace with
the rest of the world they were rejected
insulted and attacked over and over
again because of this the Jaeger ist's
believed that the only way to save the
island is to destroy the outside world
entirely they support the plan that
Aaron is apparently putting into action
because they believe that this plan even
though extreme represents their only
chance for survival unless the rest of
the world is destroyed the other nations
of the world will always see the
Islanders as a threat they will never
stop and eventually the other countries
will attack and kill every single LDN on
the island in the eyes of the Jaeger
ists this is a very simple issue either
we kill them or they will kill us either
we protect ourselves or everyone we love
and care about is going to die so with
that in mind the Jaeger is believed that
it's better to destroy the rest of the
world than to allow the rest of the
world to come and destroy them - the
Jaeger escs any plan to stop Aaron would
be an act of treason stopping Aaron now
could eventually lead to the death of
every single LDN on parody's once the
other nations of the world decide to
attack as silly as some of Locke's
actions have been it isn't hard to
understand where the Jaeger ist's are
coming from philosophically they are
doing their best to protect themselves
and their own families and after
everything that has happened in the
story so far they believe that Aaron's
plan is literally the only thing that
can save them from a cruel and hateful
world in Chapter 1 - 8 the conflict
between the warrior Scout Alliance and
the Jaeger ists finally comes to a head
the Alliance is trying to get their
hands on the azuma beto airplane
or the flying boat as they call it but
the port where the plane is currently
located is under the control of the
Jaeger ist's what's more the Jaeger ists
have captured Kiyomi azuma beetle and
other Kazuto officials including
mechanics who are essential for
maintaining the plane and enable to get
to actually fly so in order to reach and
stop Aaron the Alliance needs to secure
the plane and they need to rescue the
azuma beetle faction however the scouts
who are part of the Alliance now find
themselves in a very difficult position
in order to secure the plane and rescue
Kiyomi and the mechanics they will have
to fight against the Jaeger ist's this
means that they will likely have to kill
some of the Jaeger ist's but these
Jaeger ist's are not just random
strangers many of them are people that
the scouts grew up with here on the
island and the scouts have known some of
these Jaeger ists for many years they
even served with some of them in the
104th Training Corps Armin Mika ciccone
and Jean in particular believed that
they should save the innocent people of
the world from the rumbling they are
willing to risk their lives and are even
willing to fight their own old friend
Aaron in order to save these innocent
people but now they also find themselves
faced with the prospect of having to
kill their own fellow Islanders people
they know personally just so they could
save complete strangers in other
countries people they've never even met
understandably the scouts are conflicted
is saving innocent strangers worth
killing their own former comrades the
Marley and members of the Alliance agree
that this is a hard decision for the
scouts to make and so they offer to
carry this mission out themselves Armin
Mikasa Kony and Jean can just stay out
of this one while Annie Reiner and peak
use their Titan powers to attack the
Jaeger ists but as the Allies are having
this morally conflicting discussion
hanji warns them that time is running
out judging by the speed of the wall
titans the first ones have likely
already reached
Continent it is possible that the Marlin
cities which are on the coast and
closest to the island have already been
destroyed and that is just the beginning
even McGrath
experiences a bit of a moral crisis at
this point even he admits that up until
now he has been trying to justify his
own actions by constantly defending
Marley and demonizing the ldiots he now
finally says outright that the LDN
should not be blamed for the sins of the
past just because of their race and he
admits that the LD ends do not deserve
the mindless hatred that the world has
shown towards them
however McGrath also says that they all
have a duty to teach future generations
about the mistakes of history the
mistakes which resulted in all of this
bloodshed but of course in order to
teach future generations they first have
to make sure that humanity is going to
have a future in the first place and
that means that Aaron must be stopped
McGrath actually Baus to the scouts
apologetically but Arman says that they
the scouts must get their hands dirty
too no one will be able to just sit this
one out
meanwhile the one and only flock is up
to his old brilliant leadership tactics
yet again he tells Kiyomi and the his
Udo mechanics that everything is about
to be destroyed including their own
homeland but hey the good news is that
they will now get to contribute to the
success of parodies which is of course
the only place that any traces of
civilization are actually going to
survive it is at this point that Kiyomi
says something interesting and powerful
she says that even if Aaron's plan
succeeds the killing will not end and
suffering will not end all the islanders
are going to do is make their world
smaller but Humanity is humanity and
eventually even the people who remain in
this much smaller world will find
reasons to fight each other this is
definitely a powerful statement
depending on your personal view of human
nature
there is an argument to be made that
competition jealousy violence and hatred
are part of human nature
and no matter where you go in the world
these things are always present wherever
human beings are also present even if
all the enemies of the Islanders were
destroyed in an instant the Islanders
will just eventually start fighting
amongst each other because this violence
is part of human nature floc agrees that
Kiyomi is probably right but as long as
everyone knows their place in the world
everything will be fine and yes we all
know that our boy divine King Emperor
flock has a place at the very top of the
world he is truly an exceptional leader
with a stunning hairstyle as flock
continues to share his genius level
leadership philosophy Armin and Kony
suddenly show up on horseback and they
demand to know where Diaz Ouma Beto's
our flock opens the window and asks them
where they have been all this time
but Armin responds that there is no time
to waste they have to go after the cart
and armored Titan right now according to
Armin the two Titans have escaped the
island and they are swimming towards
Marlay the only way for the scouts to
catch them now is to use kiyomi's plane
to find them and they need Kiyomi and
the his room mechanics in order to make
the plane fly this is actually a pretty
good strategy by Armin flock is clearly
obsessed with destroying all potential
enemies of Aaron's plan so if he learns
that he now has a chance to destroy the
cart and armored Titan he will
definitely be tempted to do it he might
even be tempted to go along with Armin's
plan without resorting to any violence
or bloodshed which is exactly what Armin
is hoping for Armin and Connie then rush
off to where the plane is located the
plane is floating on the water next to
one of the piers but it is being guarded
by Samuel and dads both of these guys
are former members of the 104th Training
Corps so Armin and Clooney have known
them for a very long time although to be
perfectly honest these guys are such
minor characters that I honestly kind of
forgot that they even existed
apparently Samuel and das were preparing
to blow up the airplane and Armin and
Kony are shocked when they see the
explosives but Samuel explains that
Armin and Connie are both suspected of
working with the Marlins and the Jaeger
ist's are worried that Armin will try to
use the plane to stop Aaron Armin and
Connie denied that they would ever
betray the island and they claim to
believe that any attempt to stop Aaron
would lead to the destruction of
parodies but das says that even though
he knows Kony and Armin wouldn't betray
the island they are also the type of
people who wouldn't want innocent
civilians to die even if they are the
citizens of enemy nations this is why
the Jaeger ists are suspicious of Armin
and corny they are worried that
compassion for innocent strangers will
get in the way of their loyalty to their
fellow LD ins on the island meanwhile
flock is also skeptical about arm and
story just to be on the safe side flock
decides to start shooting the Hazara
officers if the mechanics are killed
then the plane can never take off but
flock is stopped by Kiyomi who
demonstrates some frickin epic martial
art skills and takes flock down and
disarms him instantly and before flocks
men can shoot Kiyomi Mikasa breaks in
through the window and takes out the
Jaeger ists unfortunately flock uses
this brief moment of confusion to escape
through the window and he goes on to
warn all the jaegers that Mikasa Armin
and Kony have betrayed aldia and that
they must be killed right away and that
is when all hell breaks loose as McGrath
Jean and hanji are forced to shoot a
bunch of Jager ists to save Myka sake
ami and the mechanics Armin's hope for a
bloodless confrontation is dashed in
seconds
das and Samuel then turned on Armin and
Connie and Samuel actually shoots Armin
multiple times as Armin tries to stop
dad's from reattaching the explosives to
the plane
Samuel then turns the gun on Kony
accusing his former calm
of being a traitor but in that precise
moment Reiner and Annie engaged their
Titan transformations and the sudden
explosions distract Samuel
this gives Kony the opportunity to
tackle Samuel to the ground and the two
of them begin wrestling over the gun
Armen who of course has super special
Titan shifter regeneration powers jumps
on - in an attempt to stop him from
blowing up the plane and a struggle
ensues remember that all of these guys
are supposed to be on the same side and
yet here they are fighting each other
and shooting each other how did it get
to this point how did they all get here
that is the burning question in all of
their minds in the end Kony succeeds in
grabbing Samuels gun and he does what he
hoped that he would never have to do he
shoots both das and Samuel in the head
killing them but also saving himself
armin and the airplane in the process
back on the hilltop where levi falco
gabion con point and Jelena are just
chilling and waiting Jelena says
something very meaningful and something
that echos kiyomi's words from earlier
on in the chapter
upon realizing that the attempt to
resolve the situation peacefully has
failed and that all hell is breaking
loose over at the port
Jelena says that violence is the one
thing you can't take away from humanity
and that really does seem to be the
message that the attack on Titan story
wants to teach us human nature clearly
has a violent streak and no matter what
happens we always seem to find a reason
to fight back when the LD ends of the
island were living in isolation and
complete ignorance about the outside
world they still fought they had a
secret police they made inconvenient
people like Aaron's dad disappear and so
on then when the Marlins attacked they
all fought each other and now they are
fighting each other again based on
whether they support or oppose Aaron's
plan and the cycle just keeps repeating
itself and as we know from attack on
titans history this cycle of violence
has been going on for literally
thousands of years and of course it's
not just LD ins the same is the case
with Marlay they complained about being
the victims of the LD n Empire in the
past but in the present they have their
own empire and they have been attacking
and taking over other nations they even
used Titans
their former enemies to help them
destroy these other rival nations and as
you recall even the LD and
restorationist s-- the LD ins on the
continent who had rebelled against
Marlon oppression
quickly began fantasizing about reviving
the LD n Empire and conquering other
nations it wasn't enough for them to
fight for their own rights and freedom
they quickly started thinking of
themselves as superior and they started
fantasizing about dominating other
nations I'm not sure that I personally
buy the idea that all human beings are
violent by Nature
I think that human nature is more
complex than that but I can definitely
see how humanity's history of war and
conflict can lend itself to such a
conclusion finally we arrived at the
question of who is the real traitor in
attack on Titan which of these
characters should we praise as Heroes
and which of them should we condemn as
traitors who here is doing the right
thing and who is betraying their
comrades and even their own ideals as
with most things an attack on Titan it's
all a matter of perspective with Reiner
and Annie it's probably the most simple
they betrayed their comrades of the
104th Training Corps but they did it in
the name of their original mission as
warriors of Marlay they were willing to
betray the friendship of marko and many
others and even though they felt remorse
afterwards
they certainly caused the deaths of
marko and hundreds if not thousands of
other people are they traitors yes I
would say so they betrayed people who
were nice to them and kind to them and
trusted them but the Marlins did it all
to protect their own families back on
the continent they knew that what they
were doing was wrong that is why they
felt guilty afterwards but they still
did it anyway for what they believed
was the greater good Aaron didn't betray
his comrades on the island because he
wants to save the island but you could
definitely argue that Aaron has betrayed
his own ideals from the very beginning
of the story Aaron always wanted to be
free he wanted to explore the world and
he wanted to fight for justice after
losing his own mother to the Titans he
wanted to kill every single Titan so
that no one would ever have to suffer
like he suffered but once he learned the
cruel reality about the outside world
Aaron did essentially the same thing in
labarie oh that the Marlon Warriors did
to him and his family in chigan China
and eventually Aaron decided to destroy
the outside world in order to protect
the island in so doing Aaron betrayed
his childhood ideals instead of
exploring the outside world he decided
to destroy it instead of protecting
humanity from the Titans Aaron is using
the Titans to destroy most of humanity
in that sense Aaron is definitely a
traitor he is a traitor to everything
that he used to believe in we can argue
that Aaron had to make this choice once
the cruel truth about the world was
revealed but the fact remains that Aaron
betrayed his own ideals and what about
Mikasa Armin Levi and the other Scouts
they believe that Aaron's plan is too
extreme and they are willing to team up
with their own former enemies in order
to protect the innocent people of the
world from the rumbling but even though
many of us can sympathize with their
desire to protect millions of innocent
people we still have to recognize that
the scouts are betraying the interests
of the Islanders at least to some extent
for one thing they are willing to kill
their own fellow Islanders the Jaeger
ists in order to protect some complete
strangers they do so reluctantly but
they are still doing it now you can
certainly argue that the Jaeger ists
don't represent the true interests of
the Islanders you can argue that the
Jaeger ists have been led astray by
flock and his fanaticism but you cannot
deny the fact that actually stopping
Aaron could one day bring about
destruction of parodies now that the
rumbling has been initiated the entire
world will see the danger that the
Islanders posed to the other countries
and so if Aaron is somehow defeated and
the rumbling is somehow stopped before
the other nations are destroyed then
paradise will be in grave danger just
think about it the island is now without
its walls without the wall tightens and
technologically it is far behind the
rest of the world this means that if any
country decides that paradise is too
dangerous they could attack the island
and destroy everyone on it pretty easily
and now that the world has seen the
horrors of the rumbling you can bet that
they will be even more scared of the
Islanders and that they will be even
more eager to destroy parodies and
everyone on it
if Armin Mikasa and the other Scouts
have some sort of brilliant plan that
can stop Aaron and protect the island at
the same time then we can argue that
they aren't traitors and that they are
actually doing the right thing but if
they end up stopping Aaron and the
island is attacked by foreign nations as
a result then we have to concede that by
staying true to their moral convictions
about protecting the innocent people of
the world they betrayed the interests of
the people on paradise itself so their
desire to protect innocent strangers
could lead to the death of everyone they
know and care about on the island and
this is the brilliance of attack on
Titan depending on which perspective you
take almost anyone can be considered
either a traitor or a hero
except for flock of course because flock
is undoubtedly the true hero of the
entire story anyway as we know in the
real world our own world most wars and
conflicts have multiple sides to them
and so depending on which side you're on
you will have a vastly different
perspective on who is the good guy and
who is the bad guy and the same goes for
who is the hero and who is the traitor
with a few notable exceptions like
germany in world war ii where even the
Germans themselves agree that their side
was in the
most real-world conflicts are incredibly
complicated and everyone believes that
their site is right and that the other
side is wrong attack on titan does a
great job of bringing this reality to
life and the story of attack on titan
really forces us to ask ourselves why
the human race continues to turn to
violence and it also forces us to ask
ourselves of why we are so prone to
looking at the world as if things were
just black and white
when in reality things are not so simple
they are usually extremely complicated
and instead of black and white they are
a million shades of gray this uncanny
ability to shine a mirror to our own
world and to our own human nature is one
of the reasons why I love attack on
Titan and I honestly can't wait to see
how this amazing story is going to end
now please feel free to give me your own
perspective on who the real traitors are
down in the comments below there is no
wrong answer since your opinion will be
based on whichever subjective
perspective you choose to take but I
would be curious to hear your opinions
and your reasoning if you enjoyed this
video and you want to see more attack on
titan content here on the channel please
leave a like to let me know and if you
happen to be new to anime uproar don't
forget to subscribe and hit that
notification bell to turn on all
notifications if you don't go through
the trouble of clicking the bell and
then selecting the option that says all
you're gonna miss a lot of our videos
it's just how YouTube works you can also
hit me up on Twitter and/or
Instagram at anime uproar don't forget
to check out our generous sponsors
summoners war for free link in the
description as always thank you guys so
much for watching and until next time
see ya space cowboys
[Music]